hello and welcome to national and
democracy week under lavinia handling
him and the chairman of mid Suffolk
District Council I'm the member of
refreshing Phil's Ward and I'm on the
planning committee and the scrutiny
committee good morning I'm Suzie Morley
and I'm the leader of mid Suffolk
District Council I also have three
portfolios law and governance assets and
investments and communities and digital
digital improvement
good morning John field I'm the leader
of the Lib Dem group at mid Suffolk I'm
also a county councillor and actually
today on acting for the Greens as well
and another body which we work closely
with I'm on the planning committees of
mid Suffolk and really my claim to fame
I guess is that in my local district I
have the incinerator and the plant that
sorts waste materials out so know a few
things that we contribute to the overall
area good morning I'm Katherine Grandin
I'm the paper district councillor for
Hadley south I'm chairman of paper
district council and I'm also on the
overview in scrutiny committee good
morning I'm John Ward I'm the leader of
Ava District Council I'm also the
cabinet member for finance
I represent the Bret Vale ward which is
the villages south of Hadley stretching
over to the a12 and down to the Essex
border good morning I'm Derrick Davis
I'm the cabinet member for paper for
communities I represent counties board
which is on the Shotley Peninsula so our
first question is from thirst in high
school it's from a group called be the
change our project for this half term is
to improve the litter problems in us
a local area how if the council tried to
do this and what has been successful I
believe councillor I'm Katherine Grandin
has got some question answers for this
yes in fact litter isn't really a beta
District Council or disparate council
matter it's more of a parish and town
council if you but it is something that
District Council's can help with so for
example in Hadley we've got what's
called the tidy town team it's a group
of volunteers led by lady called Anita
he's been going something like four or
five years I could have the date wrong
but it's been really successful in
Hadley in fact we've now got about
thirty volunteers who help regularly and
they love doing it this it gives them
great pride in our town and also it's
given the town pride in itself because
there's less litter around we find that
is less litter to tidy up the support
that Baber as a District Council and
myths offer give to such teams as this
is that they provide all the equipment
they need so they have the bigot their
picks the fluorescent jackets and the
bags and any other equipment that they
feel they need they can actually get
supplied from the council from the
district council and then what happens
is they gather the rubbish in bags and
leave it at a particular place in yeah
at the end of a road or something like
that in Hadley and they just send an
email to paper district council say oh
you know we've got three bags at the end
of this row please can you collect it
and it's a cooperation really between
the volunteers the tidy town
and the District Council we're all sort
of helping each other but the good thing
is it gives everyone pride in the era
they live in and our our town looks so
much nicer now and the success of this
also is shown in that now we're so clean
and tidy in Hadley that members from the
tidy town team are going to help other
areas other towns and villages nearby
and give them suggestions on how they
can make something similar work in their
area so it's been very very successful
and I do hope that your litter
initiative at your school and in your
area works works well too I'm sure
there'll be people happy to help you in
Hadley if you have any questions thank
you our second question
oh sorry John would you like to speak
about the waste plant thank you I just
cover a couple of points basically the
school in my area it's Clayton high made
sure that I financed some litter bins
for it place them at strategic points
obviously work to group like your own
work with other students to make sure
that as far as possible people put their
their waste their wrappers their various
things is that you generate during the
day in those bins so that the school was
kept more Clark tidy and they obviously
did the sort of collecting that you've
just heard about as well of things that
are escaped the bins at the first cats
you then simply have to contact the
District Council who will collect those
bins as part of the waste collection
process and it then goes on to the
materials recycling facility which says
in my ward it's been modified at the
moment so they're improving the
machinery which sorts wastes to make
sure that each particular type of
plastic and things can be sorted out
make sure there's no contamination in in
bundles of plastics that increases its
waste and obviously increases the ease
with which it can be reused
clearly litter is almost everybody's
responsibility and but in fact the
statutory duties are split so litter
litter picking is the responsibility of
the town and parish councils they also
have responsibility for things like dog
waste bins the District Council is
responsible for refuse collection and
the County Council is responsible for
refuse disposal but clearly the best
thing to do is persuade people not to
litter in the first place sorry the
second question is it's a bit of a
tricky one really if there are any
problems in our town who should we talk
to and what should we do we discussed
this earlier and our feeling was it
depends what sort of problem it is
really whether it's a you know something
that needs to be spoken to the police if
it was a County issue or or concerning
the district or even the Parish Council
as anyone yeah it there obviously that
you do have county councillors district
councillors parish and town councillors
and also of course as I said the police
but I think probably that the best thing
is whichever councillor you are most
familiar with or or or know or you know
somebody who knows family member or
neighbors or whatever that person can
then liaison your behalf and make sure
that your concern your problem gets
channeled to the right source and that
really is I think the best way of going
about this just somebody you know who
has the the right level of contacts and
authority so it could be your district
council it could be your town councilor
to be your county councillor whichever
is the one that you know the best right
our next question is um one of the
biggest issues at our school is the
school bus situation is making lots of
students worried what can be done about
this Derek would you like to answer that
yeah school bus transport is run by the
County Council but of course as John
just mentioned about know people and
being able to go to the right people
your district council can help in
certain ways and and and working
alongside the County Council we obey but
I'm not sure mid self as well are very
very anxious to make sure that we
improve community transport but what we
don't want to do is take over the
statutory responsibility from the County
Council because it is their
responsibility the council tax that you
pay goes towards the school transport
there's certainly areas which need to be
improved I think central government can
play a part in helping on that and then
the County Council but certainly a
district level we're looking more
closely at how we can help community
transport and including making sure
those buses are running for you guys
early in the morning and in the evenings
yes as a county councillor I just add a
few points to that I mean clearly the
county has caught a massive home to
school transport budget is about 17
millions a year and as you probably all
aware that the government has been
reducing the amount of funding it
provides to counties for a number of
years now it makes it quite difficult to
tackle these problems there's a also an
issue that certain children children
with special education needs perhaps are
becoming somewhat more common we're our
dentists on issues more frequently and
they require some quite expensive
transport so that there's a problem how
do you optimize the transport across the
county to get best value for people's
money and currently as you know they've
changed the the areas school captain
catchment areas they've changed people
right to free transport to just those
areas that to schools that are closest
to your home and that has produced some
stress I think the county has got a
group looking at that issue but
fundamentally it's a finance problem we
need basically more cash to provide a
warder transport we've just had another
question from Thurston Community College
what are our main priorities at the
moment and why and John I believe you
want to start with this thank you yeah
well three things from my point of view
firstly together the two districts are
putting together a new local plan which
will determine the planning policies for
the next 18 years and this is essential
that we have up-to-date policies that
we'll be able to deliver the housing
that we haven't been asked to deliver by
central government in conjunction with
that housing generally not just the
housing that developers provide on the
open market but also the two councils
are committed to building more council
housing because we know that we have to
increase the amount of council housing
we have to provide housing at affordable
rents for people so those are the first
two things and then and finally the
other thing is having sound finances and
not just in terms of the budget for the
coming year but also for the next few
years beyond that local authorities
across the country are suffering cuts in
central government support and
increasingly we're having to look not
just at it new innovative ways of
working to make savings but also where
we can get additional sources of funding
that doesn't revolve involve just
getting government grants or increasing
council tax because we are limited to
what we can do in terms of council tax
increases as well so therefore we're
we're doing things like investing in
property to get additional income all of
this is to ensure that we maintain our
services and a paper amid suffer we have
been very fortunate in the past four or
five years we haven't had to cut any
services despite the title financial
restraints that we're having to face so
those are three things that the local
plan housing delivery and having sound
finances for the future
do you see what would you like to add
we started out with putting customers at
the forefront of everything we do we
want to make it easier for them to
contact us especially now that we've
moved out of our district and what we've
still got our customer access point in
stone market and we're making it easier
for people to contact us by social media
our website and to talk to any of us you
can email you can talk to your ward
councillors you can talk to your counter
your district councillors and we're just
trying to make it easier almost every
form that you ever use to contact the
council is now online and we can respond
far quicker to that and it's also easier
for you to do it in your own time rather
than us forcing you to talk to us
between 9:00 and 5:00 during the day
another thing that we're concentrating
on across both councils is the climate
change initiative so we've set up a
working party across Weber and mid
Suffolk to look at what we can do to
mitigate against the carbon initiatives
that we need to be taking and also as
the Suffolk public sector leaders group
we've set up a working party there so
that not every District Council has to
be researching the same set of facts to
find out how we're measuring up so those
are the things that but there's both
both of our councils are focusing on at
the moment yeah and one of the things
that fall under my particular portfolio
and I work very closely with the Judi
Flatman mid Suffolk and one of the
things we're very concerned about is the
rising levels of obesity among young
people so during the summer we jointly
had an initiative for free swims for for
under-17 for you guys and I'm delighted
to say and I can tell you right now
because we're just about to announce it
and you're the first to know that we're
going to extend those free swims
throughout the october half term and
into Christmas and so you can go along
too
- useful impulse and I guess the newest
ones for you would be mid Soviet leisure
center stone market or destroyed book
swimming pool fitness center and in
South Suffolk babe we've got the
Kingfisher pool at Sudbury and Hadley
ledger Center as well so please if you
haven't already registered register and
come along and enjoy free swimming just
wanted reinforce ours again the bit that
we really passionately interested in the
environment climate change carbon
emissions and biodiversity and as Susie
said we were working together to try and
get some real solutions to some of those
problems it's far from simple with their
obviously global problems there's
certainly things that mid Suffolk and
Suffolk County Council can do
improve matters and we're absolutely
passionate that we must find things and
get on with doing them not just talk
about them thank you we have another one
from Thurston Community College saying
do you think we should focus on
recycling and make that a priority John
would you like to answer that definitely
we think that should be a priority it
has been for some time as I said this
quite an expensive plant having some I
think it's about 15 million spent on on
improving its performance but it clearly
depends critically upon you at home
putting things in the recycling bin not
just our Dooley young put it in a min
your black bin because that's easy
you must sort them out we really need to
work I suppose as well with various
shops providers of materials to make
sure the amount of packaging they use is
not only minimized which is the best
thing to do with it but easy to recycle
so it can be identified you know which
Bennett goes in and you can make sure
that our recycling percentage is rising
they're already quite acceptable but
they can rise further yes recycling is
is critical for
Balaam is suffer as it is for other
authorities our recycling rates are good
that they have stalled we're not
increasing as fast as we would like
which is why we've got this extra
investment in the recycling facility
which services not just paper miss
Suffolk but the whole county but one of
the key things is to ensure that there's
as little contamination in our recycling
bins as possible so we do encourage
people to make sure they only put their
things in that the blue bins that can be
recycled and that other material is kept
out but the other good thing in in
Suffolk that we are extremely proud of
is the fact that our landfill is
virtually negligible because we do have
the the waste incinerator the energy
from waste plant so that anything that
doesn't get recycled goes straight to
that and gets turned into electricity
and that that really is a facility we
can also be proud of so we're doing the
very best we can
not just in favour and miss Suffolk but
across the county all of the authorities
in the county working together Katherine
thank you one of the things I like about
the system that we have in our district
is that recycling camp is made very
simple for the user for the residents we
simply put things in blue or black bin
or if you have a brown bin you might
have to do that to you in some other
parts of the country it has become very
complicated and I think that can be very
difficult for people to use in our area
it's simple it's very successful and
it's not too burdensome for residents I
believe there's a an initiative going on
nationally isn't there at the moment to
look at how recycling and how the whole
system can be improved nationally
because I think that's one of the things
in in the country is that there isn't a
single system so you may go to another
part of the country and they might have
six bins for their recycling system so I
think our system here it is one to be
envied from many points of view
and it'll be interesting to see what
because I think that nationally they're
trying to look at a more unified system
of recycling so it'll be interesting to
see in the future once the it's all
being finished being looked at what the
final outcome is it's easy yes I think
you'd probably be quite surprised to
spend to realize how much we spend time
talking about rubbish and if any of you
are listening I've been listening to
Katherine talking about blue bins in mid
Suffolk our bins are green so don't
worry if you haven't got a blue bin
that's perfectly fine it's worth noting
as well that recycling if things go in
the recycling that are not recyclable it
can result in the entire refuse lorry
having to tip everything into the
incinerator if the if the lorry is
contaminated with non recyclable waste
then it can't go in the recycling plant
so encouraging people to put only
recyclable stuff in either the blue bin
or the green bin is absolutely
imperative and the other thing I'd like
to say is that nothing that comes
through our waste goes into landfill
everything that is not recyclable goes
into the incinerator and actually
generates heating and energy
to go into the grid Thank You vets more
questions coming in from Thurston
College what types of land you think
will be used to UM build these new
houses on will it take up farmland or
green spaces John would you like to
answer that inevitably it will take up
some some farmland some green space in
the two districts we have very little
brown brownfield zone that we can
develop so we are going to have to use
some green land the majority their
houses will be on Greenland and that's
just a factor of where we are and we are
rural districts and we don't have any
choice we have to build in Baber
420 houses a year over the next 18 years
I'm not sure what the mid Suffolk number
is is 560 something in mid Suffolk which
when you look at the size of the two
districts and not onerous targets but
and and most most of the that the
building will take place around our
major towns the major transport
corridors so there are a lot of villages
and not going to be seriously impacted
by this at all and we're doing our best
to make sure that the the development is
in sustainable locations and where we
can provide the infrastructure that the
road improvements our schools the
hospital doctor surgeries and other
facilities that are going to be needed
so that that's just that the factor of
where we are we will have to use green
land in mid Suffolk only 3% of our land
mass is actually built on at the moment
we don't have an awful lot of brownfield
sites that we can reuse so inevitably
some of the the new
it will actually go on on greenfield but
given that only 3% is built on at the
moment we should we must be able to find
space to give our people houses and
places to live that they can call home
yeah thank you I think one of the
important things is is that residents
you know you guys encouraging your
parents to decide where we're going to
build these houses we have a thing
called a neighborhood development plans
which which are coming out and you can
encourage your own village community to
have these neighborhood development
plans and the big part of that is it's
down to the residents the residents say
yes we accept we have to have a certain
amount of building and yes we have a
target that we need to meet but we want
these types of houses in these places
and we don't want developers just coming
in taking over a huge swath of land and
saying that's what you have in with no
with no input from the local residents
all it does is cause upset you want to
see the process so it's down to you you
know and please just let us know you
know what what type of house and you
think is right get engaged with your
neighborhood develop a plan if you've
got one in your area well and coming up
and and be part of it get in touch with
you your district counselor you know
because we are the ones that are
responsible is the planning authority as
well get in touch right and phone them
and say you know we think this this is
what we'd like to see it could be that
you want four or five bedroom houses
could be really just one single bedroom
flats or smaller two beds because people
want to downsize and I know youngsters
like yourselves go off to university or
go wherever you go to work for a while
but you'd like to come back to your
community you're certainly on the
Shotley Peninsula one of the biggest
things we've got is you know parents
saying our children want to live here
but there's nowhere for them so we need
to build a right that sort of houses in
the right places for you don't would you
like to accent
just a bit agree with all the points
that we made really the point I was
gonna make in my division
there's about 1900 houses to be built
over a considerable period of time at
the moment there's about 400 being 417
being built on what was an old cement
work site
so there are brown feel it's how it's
being used and there's another 150
destined for what used to be a said of
our warehouses that unfortunately burned
down recently but they were ancient
Victorian warehouses so I think people
are trying to build on brownfield land
where they can but this has been said
there's not a great supply of it in the
district and after that one has to build
I guess on farmland but we try and make
sure that's on the lowest quality
farmland not clearly the highest quality
farmland it exists thank you from our
next question is um do we have any
specific ideas reducing co2 emissions
has anyone got any young feelings about
that sorry to come back immediately but
yes I think there's the housing
rebuilding has to be at the highest
environmental standards we can manage
we'd like to see it built to Passivhaus
standard but that could be a bit
expensive so we've got to have a good
compromise there but anything to reduce
the amount of co2 you generate heating
your home he's good it's also good
there's been mention that the buildings
are put in sustainable locations or
either there's decent public transport
or they're within walking distance of
schools so you have the option of
getting to your your work your school
without generating too much carbon it's
a couple of things
reducing car usages for ours we
practically Karin is another issue
moving towards electric vehicles rather
than petrol driven vehicles I think it's
probably enough to be going on with
[Music]
yeah I echo a lot of what John said we
need to make sure when we do have new
housing schemes that they are that they
do encourage walking and cycling as much
as they provide for car usage as well so
the other thing is ensuring that houses
have electric vehicle charging points as
the two districts we are in installing
charging points in car parks and
elsewhere so the more of that sort of
thing we can do to encourage the uptake
of electric vehicles and to promote that
the better but a lot of it comes down to
how we design our communities to make
sure that travel is as green and carbon
free as possible and obviously of course
in house design as well to make sure we
don't use as much energy in our houses
we can also do a lot to change the way
we work
we've just issued a directive that all
our council papers
rather than having hard copies printed
and posted to councillors we have now
put a stop to all of that and all of us
have laptops or tablets to work with and
that will save the council somewhere in
the region of 50 pounds a year so
there's a lot that we can do to change
our own working habits and set an
example for other organizations
including schools businesses about how
they work we don't need to cut down
trees in order to feed our paper have it
Katherine thank you um one go back to
housing one of the things that we did do
as District Council's is introduce where
possible solar panels on roofs for our
council houses so obviously there'll be
some places where roofs may not face in
the right direction
but wherever it was feasible
we as councils installed solar panels so
that those houses now we'll have that
keeper electricity which is better for
the environment for many years to come
first of all I want to applaud young
people who have been encouraging those
that are less enlightened about climate
change and things like co2 emissions and
we do listen recently and both both
councils of adopted has been mentioned
new climate emergency paper and among
those many initiatives about
biodiversity and everything like that is
that Baber we're following the lead
given by mid Suffolk for the trees for
life so in future anybody born without
in our district the parents will get a
voucher and they can plant a tree either
in their garden or and an allocated area
somewhere else so we are doing things
but
one needs to do more and we need to keep
going and you guys yeah keep encouraging
us and again engaged tell us what you
would like thank you
the next question is um do we need more
types of bins should we at school be
separating out types of recycling waste
John I'm just gonna mention we heard me
we discussed a little earlier that the
government is trying to change the
scheme for collecting waste and
particularly they'd like to see separate
food waste collection and that food
going to in vessel composting or
anaerobic digestion some more
environmentally friendly way of dealing
with it they'd also like to see glass
collected at the curbside that would
mean additional bins and obviously I
think you don't want too many bins as we
said it gets a bit complicated if we've
got a whole lot of things if you had to
separate different types of plastic milk
bottles and and fizzy drink bottles and
things all separately it gets quite
complex I think my group would like to
see the food waste collected separately
there it does seem to be some
significant benefit that glass weiss is
currently connected bins typically where
you shop so so that seems to work quite
well and the process of putting all the
rest in a single bin and sorting it out
in Amorth in a materials recycling
facility again that seems to work
particularly well so there's what we do
is pretty good at the moment
we don't want to move away from
something that's just more - something
that's just more complicated and more
expensive one does want to see recycling
and waste treated in a better way so I
think you know my emphasis would be that
there's some merit in looking at the
food waste issue do we collect that
separately it currently goes into your
black bin into the residual waste and
goes through the incinerator
can we do something better with that a
number of other initiatives that
keen on introducing probably aren't
going to work much better than what
we're doing at the moment and could add
to cost which which is something we all
want to avoid so that'd be my view do
you think I think one of the issues that
we face is that our bin lorries are
designed to pick up things of a
particular shape and size and at the
moment we can only collect from the bins
that we have but recycling a lot of
people already use what we call the
bring sites which are the but you might
see them as bottle banks charity
recycling bins that are scattered around
the countryside near where I live my
nearest one is a Deborah Leisure Centre
so all of our BL all of our bottles go
into the the bottle banks and then they
are taken away and recited by
professionals our next question is um do
you think that the roads in Suffolk can
cope with the future amount of traffic
there are there's an act there was an
accident on the a14 last Thursday with
lots of us relate to school because the
reserve the roads were blocked what can
we do to make sure this doesn't happen
more and more as more cars to use the
road to answer this one yeah thank you
well the short answer is at the moment
we do have a roads problem in in the
county as indeed that other places in
the country do have I was at a meeting
actually in cables that Merion on Friday
afternoon it was hosted by the South
Slavic MP James cartlidge and we had
representatives I was there from the
district council their representatives
from Suffolk County Council and also
from Highways England the meeting was to
discuss particularly the a 12 and a 14
problems not just now but also in the
future as the housing numbers increase
it is a very difficult problem we all
know that both the a 12 and the a 14 are
inadequate as indeed are some of our
other smaller roads that the main roads
eh on day 14 our highways England
responsibilities there are trunk roads
but the other roads in the county are
the result
leti of the county council we the only
thing we can do is working together is
to lobby the government to provide the
funding that's going to be required and
we can do that with our MPs with our
county councillors and working together
we we know that we have a huge problem
on the a14 not just in the section that
goes straight through Suffolk to
chemistry but also particularly problems
when the or well bridge is closed and
the impact that has in its which coming
up from London and Essex the the cop top
mill interchange is totally inadequate
now for the traffic that is having to
handle so there there are massive but
very expensive projects that really do
need to be done in the county we have we
have been that the poor relation when
it's come being in terms of road funding
in the past of 10 20 years and it's very
frustrating to all of us in local
government that this is the case the
only thing we can do is to keep pushing
and pushing - for the government to help
us in this
and of course the best thing to do in
the light of our climate change
emergencies is to persuade fewer people
to be driving to work that's something
we can all do thank you John
yes I totally agree with that and add
and move as much right as we can to
rival felixstowe currently it's moving
quite a substantial proportion of
freight to the railway and that's an
efficient and quick way of moving it so
we do need to do that we do need to
increase public transport so those who
can't walk to work and have an option
other than using their car so there are
a range of things we can do all right
moving on we have um some generic
questions here oh hang on sorry we have
a new question
oh I said it here else is a to urge
people so if they have any more
questions to email them in now and we
will try and answer them as soon as we
can
our first generic question is and what
does the councillor tax pay for John
would you like to answer this though
yeah and council tax there are several
elements to the castle text although we
as District castle's collect the tax
it's not just for ourselves we collect
on behalf of ourselves the County
Council the police and crime
Commissioner and the town and parish
councils and they each of those groups
are responsible for spending money on
different things obviously the police
and crime commissioners is responsible
for ensuring we have a police force in
the county the county council spends its
proportion of the council tax on
services they provide which the things
like highways education and social
services and also some strategic
planning around minerals facilities
quarries and that sort of thing at the
district council our services go to
things are things like the Bing
Collection waste collection our housing
program council housing we're also the
planning authority so all planning
applications come to us and a heard by
us we provide things like health and
safety inspections of restaurants and
other premises there a number of
community facilities and leisure
facilities we've already talked about
the alleged centers in in stone market
and South Korean and elsewhere so there
are a number of services that we
probably provide the widest range of
services but the County Council has the
very expensive ones but fewer of them
John's already explained the types of
facilities that we we pay for but the
the actual split if you look at your
council tax bill only 10% of that comes
to us as a district council 80% of it
goes to Suffolk County Council for the
services they provide and 10% to the
police now the County Council you know
80 there 80% is in the main used to fund
their adult social care and children's
services so something like seventy five
percent of the entire county council
budget is spent on three percent of our
population and that's that is a big
issue for all of us at the moment our
10% John's already explained some of the
things that we're doing we also include
homelessness prevention in that as well
as our social housing thank you was
anything else like to add to that
so um our next question is um I have a
Parish counselor at district counselor a
county counselor and MP an MEP PCC to
contact with problems what issue should
I speak to what issues should I speak to
my district counselor about and not that
others like to start with that John yeah
okay it really comes down to that sorts
of things that we provided the District
Council but I also go back to something
I said earlier that district counselors
are the ones that we've probably closer
to the ground than some of the others
certainly the MP the MEP so really
whatever concern you have your district
councillor is is very approachable and I
know in my particular area people come
up to me and ask me about all sorts of
things but and I can channel that the
issue through to the relevant person but
in terms of the main things that people
do contact us about are things like
planning because planning is a very
emotive issue and that's that's the kind
of thing that we often I think all of us
get questions complaints and it takes up
most of our time as Ward members but
other things the only other thing of
course it might Bend collections not
being done today so we we often have to
resolve issues around miss bin
collections but all the sorts of things
that the district councillors are
responsible for but but as I say other
things as well
we're very approachable people and can
usually help us and try to resolve
either ourselves or by passing on to
somebody else most problems Thank You
Katherine yes I agree with what John
said although where the district
counselor we work quite closely as well
with the other tiers of local government
so I know the other people on my for
example in my situation a Town Council
they asked me to refer
things to find out things for them but
also if someone asks me a question which
is a town or a parish council problem I
would need to refer it on to them as
well so we all work together it's not
exactly teamwork but we know what each
other does and so if a resident you know
calls us or emails us with the problem
we are quite happy to channel through to
the right person because we need them
all really so so it's all not a problem
we're all here because we like to help
we'd like to be part of our community
giving as much help to the people in our
area as they need that's why we'd like
to become
that's why we've all chosen to become
counselors to to help our communities
you know we're all here on a voluntary
basis and the reason we do this work is
because we we want to be part of our
community and help people and guide them
when needed
so do use our services if you think you
have a problem
thank you Susie
all of our contact details are all on
our website so you can easily find out
who your district councillor is and most
of us are here because we want to make
something happen in our patch which is
whatever our patches I became a district
councillor in 2015 and before that I was
involved with demonym Leisure Centre and
as a result of me lobbying my then
district councillor for more money to
help get extra facilities for the
leisure centre I got to know my district
councillor and realized what a great job
they were doing and so a couple of years
later when she said to me why don't you
stand as district councillor I thought
well yeah and it's not about necessarily
getting really political with a big P
it's about making change happen in your
area and getting involved because at the
end of the day everything that you do
that we do comes back down to doing the
best for our communities q Derek yeah I
think to get to the number of the
question of you know what should you
come to the District Council for I think
we make it easy for you in a way because
the cabinet system divides all the
various responsibilities up so if you go
on to our paper and mid sub site you'll
see all the different portfolios so
they'll be housing so you know if you
you know a lot of the questions I get is
about housing we want to move all the
how can we get a council house of social
housing
so does that there's planning there's
the environment there's communities my
particular portfolio holder so in that
I'm the person that people will come to
for for local grants and funding for
various things and then your county
councillor has a locality budget as well
and there's someone they go to but the
district level you can start off with
community groups volunteering community
safeguard all these different issues you
know we've recently had
a couple of horrendous house fires near
where I am and our team have been able
to go out there and deal with it very
very quickly because everyone's lost who
do we go to so they were able to go to
our house the team and they were able to
give the support very quickly but
generically yeah if you've not sure
where to go please use our website
choose the sitter the particular section
that you need and get in touch and as
soon as he said all our contact details
are very very public either online or in
the local magazines and social media and
everything like that thank you
it was fun - thank you for the questions
you sent in so far and encourage you to
send in any more if you'd like us to
answer them and we've got one more
question here who decides where district
reward is and what its boundaries are
and what factors go into the decision so
you see would you like to answer that
yes I think I can answer that
and that's actually decided by the
Boundary Commission which is an
independent body set up by government to
look into that babe remit Suffolk went
through boundary changes last year and
they came into effect in May this year
and what they basically do is they try
and ensure that each district Ward has
approximately the same number of
counselors because what you don't want
to end up with is one counselor having
two residents to look after and another
ward councillor having 2,000 residents
look after so as our towns and our
villages grow and expand it can be quite
fluid and so the the Boundary Commission
looked at all our ward boundaries last
year and made a few changes and on
average I think each Ward now is
comprised of about two and a half
thousand residents of course that will
change as the populations of their
places flow and dip
yes Susie said the the actual size of a
award within the district does depend on
population and does change from time to
time so just to give you a bit of
background as you love surmise the
district is is broken down Dean into
Ward's they're the smaller units which
each council represents that the county
is broken down into divisions which
represented by a county councillor and
the same thing goes for there the idea
is to make sure that each division is
has the same sort of population and so
they are the sizes of those are reviewed
from time to time and the county is
about to go through a boundary review in
the same way that the two districts did
earlier this year the the current
structure of local government was set up
in 1974 and at that point we had one
Suffolk County Council and seven
districts and boroughs within that
County this year that's just been
reduced down to five because we've had
the mergers in West Suffolk and in East
suffer so obviously structures like that
do change but it is all determined by
central government at that level as to
where the where the boundaries are but
there is a lot of local input certainly
within the western East the decisions to
merge into the two larger units were
taken locally the Boundary Commission
were in assessing the sizes of wards and
divisions takes a lot of input and
evidence from from us as councillors so
we have a huge amount of input into that
but it is controlled by the Boundary
Commission as as others have said anyone
else like to answer any of that
if I can do if I can just add
when you vote in an election mid Suffolk
are the ones who run the election so
regardless of whether you're voting for
an MP and MEP or district councillor
County counselor or parish councilor mid
Suffolk and Baber it's always the
district councillor Council that runs
the election and our returning officer
is our chief executive arthur Chelonia
so we've had no more questions in so I'd
like to thank everyone who sent
questions in and for taking part and and
I hope you've all learned something so
thank you very much thank you thank you